my body was being
attacked from my extremities
my arms turned black and my legs turned
black
my ears the end of my nose my lips had
all started to turn black
[Music]
so prior to falling ill um
my life was
amazing in one sense and pretty tragic
in the other so i was a stay-at-home dad
for my little boy sam
and lucy and i when we had him
decided that she was the
she wanted to work she loved her work
and i
didn't i didn't want to work didn't like
my work that part of my life was
incredible it's the best job i've ever
ever had it was just lovely
and and then we had
two restaurants at that point or a pub
in a countryside in a restaurant
so i was in charge of the one in the
countryside
but i was a
heavy drinker slashed alcoholic in
reality
um my intake unit intake was
massive absolutely huge i was drunk all
day pretty much all day every day
while i was still looking after this you
know two and a half year old
and i caught what i thought was
just a man flu really
and
it's like cough snivels
it got worse and then it then it turned
into
hot and cold sweats
no appetite
and didn't drink it was just it felt
terrible really rough
and then i then took to my bed for a
couple of days and then
after about two weeks i went to the loo
in the middle of the night and there was
blood in my urine
so we knew then that something was
seriously wrong
um
and then the following morning i woke up
semi-conscious lucy had gone to open up
our other restaurant so i was in the pub
on my own
luckily my son was staying at my parents
the night before so he wasn't there
i remember trying to put jeans on
couldn't do it i remember trying to
button his shirt i couldn't do it um
and just didn't really know
who i was where i was
and then i remembered a knock on the
back door
so i staggered out from my bedroom and
and just almost like fell downstairs
really on my on my on my ass really
got to the bottom of the stairs and then
made it to the back door
and
i somehow
still had the the function to turn the
key to one locket
and when i opened the door
there was lucy my other half of my
step-dad looking at me and their faces
were just
they were horrified and my skin was
turning purple and
my eyes were popping out my head i was
in a complete mess i was shutting down
what was happening to you
so i contracted something called strep a
now it's not
very well known in
in the uk but in america everyone gets
strep throat so they're they're more due
to it over there but over here
um when we were told i had strep a we
didn't really know what it meant
but the strep led to
toxic shock syndrome septicemia
necrotizing fasciitis
at that point when i got the man flu
which is probably all it was initially
and for whatever reason my immune system
was
incredibly low and didn't
or couldn't be bothered to fight off the
the incoming infection so
prior to me turning up in winchester i
think they had six cases of strep a
or seven i think including me
and i think i was the only one to make
it out alive
and basically all my my body was being
attacked from my extremities um by the
strep
and all strep wants to do is destroy
what's in his path
to get to my heart to kill me
and hence why
my arms turned black and my legs turned
black
my ears the end of my nose my lips had
all started to turn black
so in the course of probably
seven or eight days my body was in a
complete
state of disarray i was being kept alive
by a
huge amount
of steroids and drugs
and they said to lucy and my mother
who'd arrived in hospital on the the
third day
that
your your son your partner isn't going
to survive he's more than likely going
to die
and you need to go away this evening
and we'll wake him in the morning but
prepare to say your final goodbyes
and i woke the following morning
um
looking around thinking where where the
hell am i what's going on
how did you feel though what was going
through your mind
and i think when i arrived in salisbury
again we didn't know what was happening
really until i met my plastic surgeon
who
is a this beautiful woman who just
wafted into my room and said oh
how are you i said i'm you know i'm
great how are you
and she says you're not very well
um and i think
we'll certainly amputate your left arm
above the elbow
uh we'll amputate your feet you we may
keep your ankles but the chances are
you'll lose your feet and ankle
on both legs
your right arm we think we can save it's
pioneering surgery
but we think it can work
and you'll almost certainly undergo
facial reconstruction at some point of
the process
and then she was gone out my room
and i was there on my own
lucy wasn't there
at that point my best mate flown in from
france and he wasn't in the room
and i was lying there thinking
okay i must be heavily drugged that
wasn't the conversation was it surely
she can't really mean i'm gonna
lose my limbs
and i freaked out i i'm mad and
i thought i did in reality i could
barely move but in my mind i'm i'm going
nuts i want to escape i want to get away
i don't want to i don't want that lady
as beautiful she is to start attacking
me with knives and cut my limbs off
and i remember my best friend coming
back in the room
seeing that i was distressed and when i
explained what gone on he just hit the
roof he was not he went mad
and then lucy found out and she went mad
but it was just the
the raw emotion of it all for all of us
was
incredible
but at that moment when you're told that
you know you're probably going to lose
everything
it was
horrifying absolutely horrifying
how many
surgeries have you been through all in
all
i don't know the number of surgeries i
think it's about 130 hours now
of surgical procedures
uh in salisbury alone winchester i don't
know
um
i guess i know 140 150 hours maybe
both legs going above the knee left arm
above the elbow
and my right arm below the elbow and
then more surgeries with
skin grafts
my
left shoulder is
rebuilt around my right arm
my right shoulder is pretty much most of
the skin on my face
and
all the skin on my back is on my legs
and skin grafts have been moved here
there and everywhere so it's been a
complete
re-mold really of my body
as i
grow older
you know skin moves in different
directions
and you know parts of your body aren't
meant to go on to other parts of your
body so it's
we're always on the lookout for problems
and
i'm always going to have
surgeries until the day i die
what do you think kept you going through
the toughest time of it all
it was my son
he was the reason
i didn't want him to grow up
without me
um
and i didn't want him to struggle with
what was happening to me as well so it
was always a
he is he is the number one we have to
get it right for him
and we have to make everything
uh any in decision everything was formed
around sam he was the basis of how we
were going to
get through it understand it talk about
it and then move forward with
or fashion a new life
once i was out of hospital
what was his reaction when he saw you
wow i mean blessed me i remember i
didn't see him from
17th november to christmas day i think
it was
and i just missed him terribly
all of a sudden i'm bored with
excitement i'm going to see my little
lad
and lucy opened the door and then he
came
and he sort of and he's a tiny little
thing he's looking around
and then he sees me in the corner
and
you could see him sort of almost stop in
his tracks and then he hid behind lucy's
legs
now i wasn't surprised about that
because
i looked terrible
and i was missing
arms
or one arm one arm in bandages legs had
gone
you know visually i was a complete mess
and not the dad that he saw
on the 16th of november the last time he
saw me with legend
and so i understood his his
you know his trepidations come towards
me he wouldn't come close all i wanted
was a cuddle
more than
anything in the world at that point
and i was kind of buoyant
staying alive staying alive just to be
with lucy peter sam
but as soon as i saw him and his
reaction like that
i just
i just sang i was
it was as bad as it ever got
was that christmas day
and this was another defining moment in
my
my journey i guess with them
was that the the sister on the walk that
night
you could see that i was down uber down
and that just wasn't
me i'm not a down
kind of guy i'm easygoing
but she could see i was clearly upset
and she rang lucy and she goes loose
look he's really bad he's never seen him
dip like this he's always been buoyant
is there anything that we can do for him
to bring in for him that would make him
cheer up as best he can
and at least he said look the only thing
he loves more than his son or as much as
his son is his dog my labrador
and she said bring her in
and then yeah christmas day that night
about nine o'clock in burst my
joyous labrador bouncing around the ward
everything that was lacking really in
that in that huge cavernous room full of
people that were
predominantly on their deathbed really
and then this labrador bounced in and it
was just this amazing moment for all of
us
and
i've never ever heard of a story where
in intensive care you would allow a
labrador to come in see a patient
um and it was just that
act of kindness from that one
sister on the ward
that just changed everything for us
i've seen so much nhs over the years and
i'm just
astounded how amazing it is
when you need it the most and we needed
it the most at that point
um
and i just have the utmost of respect
for
anyone that works there the level of
care that i received was
it completely
shaped
who i am now
because of what they did
what were those first several months out
of the hospital like
they were pretty good only because of
my best friend really
um
[Music]
so when it came to leaving salisbury
and i was putting in all the effort on
the rehab so i was doing my sit-ups i
was doing all the
the kind of yoga pilates exercises that
i was given by the rehab team
when it came to leaving my best friend
would fly in every two weeks when i was
eight flying just gonna come and see me
have a chat
he lived in court still does bless him
living the dream in the mountains
and he was so happy out there
and he he came in for the last weekend
of my stay and he said look
what why are you worrying about going
home you know don't know it's going to
be great right surely you must be
itching to get out and i said well i am
but
you know i don't want lucy to feel that
she's gonna
have to be my carer for a period of time
i don't want my son to think that i
can't do anything you know what what's
dad doing sounds so good just doing
nothing
and i said connie i can't go to the loo
and then the more i talked about it the
worse i got i got more stressed about it
and he's like
you don't need to worry about that
something
and i said yeah but i have to worry
about it because
the impact is on them
you know and i don't want to be that
negative impact
and he said no you don't understand i've
given up my job in course your vow and
i'm going to move in you guys and
you know we'll figure it out you know
what you need how you eat how you drink
how we get around
you know you don't
you know we don't want you to worry
about that sort of thing
so he gave up six months of his life to
live with me and lucy and sam and the
labrador
and he made it
doable really you know we learned to
put straps around my arm to slide a fork
into position we learned to
adapt
tommy tippy kids drinking cups that i
could drink
um
[Music]
we learned
two ways to go to the loo i didn't need
assistance i would learn how to put my
clothes on without assistance
yeah i wouldn't be sat here now talking
to you guys
if i hadn't had that six months with him
so what would you say is the one thing
which you miss most
hitting the golf ball
i still love playing golf
love it
it's such a lazy man sport that was my
sport
everything else in my life
has found its way back
uh or to you know to a point
i mean to be honest i do probably 100
times more than i used to do
but i still haven't been able to hit a
golf ball not properly
but we do we have tasks and students in
bath they haven't made a golf suit which
we're going to develop this year
that will enable me to twist around on
my off-road
motorbike slash wheelchair
lean over the back
and there'll be prosthetics stitched
into a jacket which i'll zip up
and it will hold the golf club with the
elbow joint it should enable me to be
able to hit the golf ball
so hopefully this year would be the
first time i've hit a golf ball in
eight and a half years
and that moment alone
will be
magic
you know i just assume that people like
me would want to be involved in these
projects and want to
help the students to come up with these
great ideas but actually when you
actually when you got into unis it was
the opposite they couldn't get people on
me to come in so
i've been a guinea pig for six years now
all over the world
and i love it
that kind of leads me on to the question
which i want to ask you
about what you do now
um so what i do now is a massive list
really i'm a public speaker a public
speaking company i've been very
fortunate to speak all over the world
about
resilience living loss learning to come
to terms with it we have the alex lewis
trust which is a trust fund that was set
up for me i'm a director of something
called the wild wheelchairs project
which
and a couple of years ago we took a
university built hand cycle four wheeled
hand cycle
with a solar panel roof and a battery
pack behind it
and we cycled up ethiopia's highest
mountain
and we set up a
wheelchair facility over in barcada
making affordable wheelchairs for
um
ethiopians with various disabilities
predominantly through polio but a lot
through
war
all of this work is going to help
tons of people
you know the the prosthetics have
already helped
i think we raised 700 000 pounds at the
back end of the sort of start of last
year
so every child in the uk under 10 with
limb difference gets a free arm
for everything that's been
put into me
the millions of pounds in healthcare
the constant healthcare
the least i can do is to
continue working
and trying to make it better for others
so really my
my my working life my career started
about eight years ago
it wasn't when i was 33 certainly not i
didn't do enough with my
my education
the life i had
i didn't make the most of it
and i regret that massively
what would you say your biggest
achievements to the date
biggest achievements day by far is my 11
year old son
he's cool he's kind he's generous with
his time he he is a
mechanic slash
prosthetist physiotherapist he does
everything
stuff that i can't do he will do he
knows how to fix my wheelchair he knows
how to take my wheelchair apart
and he's like you know dad it's just
it's amazing that you can do all this
stuff
limb loss is by far the best thing
that's ever happened to me
because it altered
my life
completely
you know nothing has been the only
constant in my life is lucy and sam
and my best mate in my family everything
else has been all over the shop
and live lost has given me
access to things i never thought i would
ever do or dream of doing
so whether it's
cycling in the desert whether it's
kayaking around greenland
yeah i kind of roll out of bed every day
thinking
i'm lucky i'm a lucky guy
very lucky
[Music]
i got onto the left hand
wing
clambering over that door lip and then i
stood onto the wing and was able to
stand on the wing momentarily i jumped
i would estimate a height of about
fifteen one five feet